okay next next super chat pearl you've
had your mom on the channel a few times
her advice was to listen to your man and
always say yes to him sexually curious
to see if the panel would take that
advice oh so i'll take the [ __ ] down
my mom always said one of the reasons so
my parents have been married close to 30
years we i have nine siblings clearly
oh she was saying yes all the time
and that's one of the things she told me
she like i liked him it's awkward raised
my mom but she was like to make like i
asked her like what are the keys to like
a long healthy marriage and she said one
of the keys like if you don't want your
husband to like step out is to just
always say yes because men have like a
higher sex drive than us okay that is
true but what if like one night you're
just tired and he like hey babe let's
get it on he just said
yes and you're just like because that's
where there's like mutual respect factor
though
yeah like you need to know like when's
the time to please your man and do a
thing for him but like vice versa yeah
if you don't want it like that then it
shouldn't be a [ __ ] conversation it
shouldn't be a like it should be no
[ __ ] big yeah
i don't want to do that if you're with
someone that has gone through sexual
abuse in their life intimacy is a lot
different it's not just as simple as
let's have sometimes you know you have
bad days you have good days so
you need to be with a partner if you
like personally i was actually used like
with like in
many different facets so like my partner
has to be very understanding with me
yeah so the patient like i have a friend
who's mormon right so i don't know if
your your mom is specifically like
catholic catholic
i know you were but i don't know like
she's mormon her mom told her the same
thing told her the same thing and she
got into a situation where some things
happened with her man that she
wasn't you know i'm not gonna yeah yeah
yeah but you get what i'm saying it's
like you have to have boundaries for
yourself as a woman like our body is
like
a temper
and it's sacred like if you don't want
it to be touched if you don't want it
right no well it's not but it's not but
it's not in a way like like she does it
because she has to like she loves my dad
yeah yeah and what about you but that's
the key though is that she's okay with
that if she doesn't feel violated then
it's okay by all means she could do that
as much as she wants
but
me speaking as somebody who's also been
sexually abused like i've been in that
position where it's like i feel
obligated to please my partner but i'm
not comfortable with it and it's like
they can clearly clearly see the
discomfort in me and not respect that
then
you start to wonder if they just see you
as a sexual being if they just see you
as a toy rather than an actual person
that experience something so terrible so
yeah on the flip side do you guys think
there's ever a point where it's like
it's been too long
like because in my opinion like if you
haven't had sex with your husband in
like two or three years he's going
somewhere
i'm going to show my teeth like
like
me
like and i wouldn't even blame them like
i guys have to like do this guys
so easy for us to sit here and write
your yours are gonna hate me because i'm
anti-man and that's fine
it's very easy it's a complicated [ __ ]
it's easy to write off men to be like
well they like they're [ __ ] animals
no they're they're
i don't advocate cheating i've never
advocated i don't think it's cool to
cheat but what i'm saying is like i
think you have some level of
responsibility as a wife to have sex
with your husband i understand like so
if you haven't done it in like two or
three years like i think i would
understand if he left or told you he was
going to sleep
that's a part of being in a relationship
that's part of being in a relationship
yeah two or three years that's different
than like if you go through like two or
three months where you're not having sex
okay yeah
not only that how complicated is the
relationship or marriage for that person
to not want to be sexually active that's
the thing like what is he doing that's
making her uncomfortable have you ever
seen a couple where the girl feels like
she's settled and she's not really into
him but she just wants like kids you
never seen that
but i'm saying
but i'm saying a lot of times the guy
doesn't know that
he doesn't know like
he couldn't blame him for that if he was
to step out that's what that's what i'm
saying yeah yeah relax as well like he
can't expect that communication from her
he's not delivering that himself like
that's where there's a two-way well
right i mean i think like if you cheat
i'm with you i don't advocate cheating
but i would understand if he wanted to
get a divorce on the grounds he hasn't
had sex in three years if he vocalized
that divorce and that separation issues
and then cool down his thing
fair enough yeah if he was to go be
petty and be like cool i haven't got
anything for my wife you might not even
know the reason i say she got a bruised
or kidnapped or something
like she didn't feel comfortable telling
you she didn't want you to look at her a
certain way what is understanding but
why don't you jump to be communication
yeah definitely but it's still lack of
communication on his part like he can
never say he was on the right the
emotion
no i'm with you i don't agree with
cheating like i i'm never going to
advocate for cheating i don't think it's
cool to cheat
but i understand like where men are
coming from when they haven't like
because they're that happens a lot
they've been getting put on a victim
also i think it's important to know like
in the day and age we're in there's
temptation everything everywhere let me
tell you if you have a fine man or a
fine woman there are people waiting
waiting
patiently waiting so it's like you kind
of do like you know okay also like i'm
not saying women aren't but men are a
lot more like visual yeah women we're a
lot more internal emotional what are you
doing for me like like an exchange of
like goods almost like what are you
doing that kind of turns us off yeah the
things you can like almost give us in a
way but like men are like they'll see
something and they want it and they're
like oh sparkly like
well they're they're more they're more
visual
and also sex doesn't have like like it's
it's not as much to them as it is to us
as a woman i'm not gonna get a pic and
be like
oh my god but he's a man like he's gonna
get a picture of a kid
and he's gonna be like i need to [ __ ]
this [ __ ] right now so it's like as a
woman you have to kind of be aware of
that
it's about if what you want like if you
really want this say i'm a man i've got
my partner
if i want my man enough no other guy
will tell me that i could maybe look at
a ground block oh yeah you'll find this
part i don't mean i want you though
actually you can just like you guys are
attractive
but i might think yeah you're attractive
i could even think just as attractive
doesn't mean i want her yeah and i could
have a man
well do do you think cheating
do you think do you think cheating is
different for men and women
really
um the principle is the principle no no
we're not we're not talking about we're
not talking about the principle though
so what i'm saying cheating is different
for men and women i think men can have
sex with someone they don't even like
and never want to see again we're girls
like you're keeping a moment
i could do that too
but
do you feel like that's the norm because
i don't feel like that's what is the
norm what like who defines that norm i
mean statistics
and like that like
statistics general data anecdotal like
you can take i was going to say that men
are very much heat of the moment type of
cheaters and when it comes to women it
sometimes can be more on the emotional
side because when you have a partner
that you love dearly but you feel like
you're not getting enough from them
emotionally you might try to find that
out elsewhere and that becomes a problem
and that's why oftentimes men feel like
it's worse when girls cheat because
they're like damn
that that's because it's emotionally
available okay and like you know my
girls because because
because
women from what i've seen tend to cheat
up so like if they're cheating it's like
there's a wreath
we were even saying earlier like oh we
have to be worried about the ugly girl
like you know you know because men will
sleep with like goddamn anything but
like women like if you're cheating from
what i've seen like usually the guy that
they're cheating with has something the
partner doesn't have where the girl if
he cheats it's like she'll have nothing
to say yeah
yeah i have cheated before hi nice to
meet you
i never said i was a good person so
in my experience it was like mentally i
was done like i didn't want to be with
you
anymore like
no i'm so serious like i was like so
done and like it just he wouldn't leave
me alone and i kept trying to break up
with him the nice way and then it was
like i felt stuck
it for certain reasons and then i would
just like mentally i was done i cheated
and i was like i don't care anymore
because you hurt me in so many ways
emotionally that's brought me to this
point where
i don't care and like now
looking back yes i regret those actions
because that's not right i could have
just put my foot down and not been a
weak [ __ ] and then like i don't want to
be with you which i actually did do and
he just like would tell me no
don't know how the [ __ ] that was
probably like when my therapist told me
i was bipolar and i told her no
but you know like i feel like
for me personally not speaking for all
women but it was like uh i didn't care
like because i was done i would left the
relationship mentally way before i
cheated
i feel like some women when they do
cheat it's not like
initially or like when they
it's not the intention yeah
it'll be like build up so they'll start
talking to somebody they'll be they'll
be fed emotionally and then it gets to
that point where it's like okay i'm
gonna have sex with you and i feel like
not all women but i feel like that
emotional like
boundary is like set and then they like
keep building and then it ends up that's
why that's why i watch the male friends
go out and do whatever it is just pull
up to the club and they're like all
right i'm taking you home
and then the other half are just like
i'm not getting what i need yeah i need
i need to be